everyone I'm Kristen Gill with how to
Hollywood and I have Clyde hey good here
with me today thanks for having me there
God to the a-list celebs you have all of
the clients I had fun clients yes you do
and today he's going to recreate this
look on me
Erika Jayne to recreate this look please
keep watching so you know to get the air
contained look I definitely want to
extend your hair I love VAM seamless
extensions they come with clip ins
tape ins they have additional ponytails
they have an array of things but they
also have ones that have roots already
added in so you can get the perfect
combination of the hair you want and I'm
gonna do just some easy clip ins for you
so that it's removable but you can
create a new look easy to go do it for
the night sleep in it if you want to
whatever your lifestyle entail it seems
like all the girls they want the
versatility that went they wouldn't have
the Bob in life to make life easy but
they also want to have the long
luxurious hair for red carpet or
Saturday night or whatever it is so I I
deal with with Demi and kam and Kylie
and the thing is with a bob it's so
blunt to make sure the transition is
good you have to break up the Bob quite
a bit which it makes you you know put in
a few more hair extensions especially
through the back here so now I've added
extensions all through the back I've
broken up your bob where it's like
invisible I've done like some straight
pieces and some some pieces with wave
like a beachy wave in there a kind of a
variation of colors so in and so it has
like a textured look to it and now look
you've got an elongated look we're on
our way
oh my god we're still gonna break this
up Wow oh my gosh so we have added some
extensions in here getting the length
and the look going oh my god I'd like to
work on now you've got a kind of a mixed
up texture here which is on its way we
love that that air collects like always
like a really chunky texture we actually
we have names for different textures
like when she's sitting down to an enter
you know she's like I was feeling like
toddlers in tiaras can we do all the
twist and the young and the toys and the
fun stuff we've got a Princess Peach
you know our ultimate now for this
season we're going for Russian hooker if
that's okay
which is a big ponytail with track suits
oh my god she's so fabulous we love it
yes we all come together you get the
character reference and then we all run
with it as far as textures but sometimes
we'll actually pull out oh we need that
Downs hair with Dallas hair has more of
a fluff to it it's got like a brush and
a fluff we've got Vegas hair which is
like lived in texture that's just been
there for a day or two and there's just
certain looks we've done in certain
cities that were like Boston and we know
what we're talking about situation so
let's give you our ultimate Erika Jayne
texture is actually called calamari
Watson and it's been around for several
years and it is just so textured that it
almost looks like an octopus oh I love
it so many tentacles so many tentacles
and we're gonna go for that my favorite
heat protecting spray that actually
holds the curl and lets you just build
on texture is the orb a soft lacquer
when you spray it it can feel a little
sticky I'll admit when you put the heat
on it it all becomes magic so I'll do
that in like like two to three inch
sections and take the iron I like a
smaller iron and I rely on my golden
heart because her hair so long and this
has such a long barrel then I can start
there twist and wrap twist and wrap
twist and wrap so you wrap around you
don't use the clamp I do not use the
clamp I don't want any marks or anything
I want it to have a looseness to it so
I'll do that kind of roll it within
there drop it down and let it like
elongating it sewn how long does it
usually take you to get Erika Jayne
glammed up and ready I will say we love
to give it like a full two hours for
glam just cuz you know there may be
snacks involved or you know there may be
a round of shots or who knows
so hopefully girls have learned by now
instead of big babydoll curls the cool
way to do your hair is to spin your hair
away from your face in their twist and
twist as you go down the hair and that
gives it more of a loose relaxed beachy
wavy vibe
Ericka always has these like toys and
different like glitzy glam things in her
hair yes
can I have some you can so are you ready
for Candyland I'm so ready this is how
we play
we always love a little princess a
little crown I like that I can add a
bunch of toys let's do it and keep going
and we just like to put them in like a
little crazy why don't you help me here
let's see what like this is amazing
right here we need one over here yes
ma'am yes right and I actually play with
Erika like this I'm like help me you got
a good eye girl let's just see
you're being timid no I know I've never
done this before yeah
ready question time
here we go here we go that was fine yes
this is great you got super playful like
you tell the audience I want to know too
I mean obviously I I know I followed
your career for a long time but how you
got your start oh Lord
now I'm telling to myself well I did
start with Toni & Guy which is a major
great hair company and I traveled with
them and did their shows and tours and
it was the 80s so there's all about hair
and when we traveled we were treated
like rock stars and always wanted that
anyway so um that was a cool way to
start but I I'm from Dallas southern can
you tell um I went to an agency there
Kim Dawson agency they go oh my god can
you fly to Houston tomorrow to do the
bangles for the cover of Spin Magazine
and I'm like what yes I can't anyway
hopefully you all know who the bangles
are walk like an Egyptian oh my god but
it sent me into that world and I'm like
this is freaking for me let's do this so
um that was the beginning of my career
and that was my very first job with the
cover spin and you've worked with the
Kardashians the Jenners you've done some
of Kim's most iconic looks thank you
what I love to think that yeah oh my
gosh you've been with them since the
beginning actually they want I met Kim
on Playboy and I met Kris that day and
she's like we're about to shoot this
show but you were in the intro for
keeping of the Kardashians right you ran
in and touched up the hair where's Kim
what's one of your favorite iconic
moments that you've done for Kim
God she's had so many amazing moments
especially lately there was a special
moment when it comes to the Emmys 2010
because Kim had been sexy cam for so
long and then all of a sudden she
appeared as this Grecian goddess and I
had done something I had never done with
her hair like texturize it and did it up
in this rap and actually did accessories
and her whole the whole back of it was
embedded with Lorraine Schwartz jewel
court and um that was like a turning
point I think for red carpet with her
all right Clyde thank you so much for
being here thank you my gosh I'm gonna
be going out to be amazed
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you subscribe to entertainment a
nice YouTube channel and let us know in
the comments down below if you have any
extra questions for Clyde or myself I
will send them his way
bye guys